c'est un euphémisme ou presque mais
emmanuel macron pourrait bien être
candidat à sa réélection
officiellement ce n'est pas encore le
cas mais officieusement tout est
méticuleusement calculer mais quand on
lui pose directement la question le chef
de l'état ne laisse rien filtrer le
mandat que m'ont confié les françaises
et les français je l'exercé ré jusqu'au
dernier quart d'heure
dites-moi la date à laquelle il faut
s'arrêter de travailler démocratiquement
c'est la fin du mandat et donc je
travaillerai jusqu'à la fin du mandat et
il ya parfois des choix importants qu'il
faut faire quelques semaines ou quelques
mois avant la fin d'un mandat si je suis
devant cette situation je le ferai et
donc étant président démocratiquement
élu avec un terme j'agirai en cette
condition jusqu'à ce terme et la
majorité présidentielle s'activent à
commencer par cette belle photo de
famille prise le 29 novembre dernier
posant fièrement sous la bannière
ensemble citoyens un mouvement de
rassemblement créé le mois dernier en
soutien à une candidature d' emmanuel
macron en 2022 l'objectif est de
regrouper sous une même couleur la
république en marche le modem et
horizons la nouvelle formation politique
à d'edouard philippe françois bayrou
franck riester ou encore stanislas
guérini ont tressé des lauriers au
quinquennat du président lors de la
cérémonie de présentation de cette
maison commune aux allures de meeting où
le principal concerné a brillé par son
absence vous avez vu qu'on a pas
d'ambiguïté
notre souhait le soin et que j'ai moi
même souvent exprimé c'est
qu'effectivement même accompli sept
candidats puissent être élus ce parce
que je crois sincèrement qu'il est le
mieux placé qu'il souhaite transformer
le pays pour tirer les enseignements des
crises qu'on a vécu au fond
l'homme d'état et nous avons aujourd'hui
un homme d'état à la tête du pays le
comportement du chef de l'état ces
derniers mois interpelle depuis la
rentrée il a annoncé avec son
gouvernement une série d'investissements
et dettes diverses 1 5 milliard d'euros
premier à marseille 500 millions via le
bobo de la sécurité 600 millions versées
en chèque énergie 2 milliards consacrés
à la rénovation énergétique ou encore un
plan de 300 millions d'euros pour les
travailleurs indépendants
l'opposition s'insurge et l'accusent de
faire campagne avec le chéquier de la
france un quoi qu'il en coûte électorat
el kram et la caisse de l'état selon les
mots de valérie pécresse candidate ait l
air à l'élection présidentielle jean luc
mélenchon chef de file est de la france
insoumise vaslui peu loin dans ses
propos clairement emmanuel macron est
candidat et son temps de parole n'est
pas décompté comme tel il mélange les
genres d'une manière anormale il agit
comme candidat président un candidat
président qui n'hésite d'ailleurs pas à
mettre son costume de président de côté
pour affronter ses adversaires comme
avec xavier bertrand du temps où le
président de la région haute france
était en campagne dans le cadre de la
primaire des républicains un échange
glacial mi-novembre sur le dossier de la
syrie asko val notamment l'autre signe
annonciateur c'est évidemment sa
présence sur le terrain longtemps
accusée d'être déconnecté du peuple le
chef de l'état va à la rencontre des
français amplifiant ses visites à
travers toute la france depuis le mois
de septembre on voit qu'il s'agit
beaucoup sur ce terrain il a beaucoup
visité les hôtes france il est allé dans
le cher il est allé à vichy on voit
qu'il se ils se donnent véritablement
sous un nouveau jour c'est à dire un
président qui aurait une pré qu'une
préoccupation extrêmement forte pour les
territoires est ce assez pour lutter
conte un trait d'image négatif des
manuels macron qui est considéré à tort
ou à raison c'est peut être dur pour lui
mais comme un président parfois comme on
dit hors sol certainement une question
de timing pour faire comme ses
prédécesseurs jacques chirac et nicolas
sarkozy avait attendu le mois de février
pour l'annoncé emmanuel macron en
attendant avance ses pions